Speaker 1: Well, what we saw in New York
with the indictment of Trump in regard to
the Stormy Daniels hush money payment. Maybe just
the beginning likely is just the beginning of his
legal troubles, as I'm sure you're aware. And it
could get much worse very soon for him. Before we
dive into some reporting on this, something I've
been talking about a good bit on my show, you
can find that at Luke Beasley on YouTube is while
Trump should be held accountable wherever he is,
violate the law, including the Stormy Daniels
case. It's unfortunate that the Stormy Daniels
case is being the less significant one came
first when we have, as we're about to talk about
a case where he could be held accountable for
attempting to overturn a free and fair election,
pressuring election officials. The Brad
Raffensperger could call all of those things.
And that being one of the cases he's involved
in, one of the things he's being investigated
for makes the Stormy Daniels case seem less
significant. And so the fact that it came
first is unfortunate, but we could be seeing
the more important one significant with huge
ramifications also coming very soon. Take a look
at this from The Washington Post. Donald Trump's
appearance in a manhattan courtroom Tuesday
marked a singular moment in American history,
the first time a former sitting U.S. president
has been indicted on criminal charges. But Trump's
legal peril is far from over. Among those closely
watching the proceedings were state and local
officials in Georgia, where Fulton County District
Attorney Fanny Willis is expected to announce in
coming weeks whether she will file charges in
connection to efforts by Trump and his allies
to overturn the state's 2020 presidential election
results. Expected to announce in the coming weeks.
And we saw the media tour that the grand jury
foreperson did. That was strange, but it did
reveal, at least in the eyes of the grand jury,
likely charges, indictments were recommended and.
If Fannie Willis follows in that path, we could
be seeing charges very soon in regard to what I
see as the most important thing. Trump is being
investigated for. If you somehow have forgotten
what this is all in reference to, or one of
the elements of this investigation here was the
infamous Georgia call, or at least a part of it.
Speaker 3: So all I want to do is this. I just
want to find 11,780 votes. So tell me, Brad, what
are we going to do? We won the election and it's
not fair to take it away from us like this. And
it's going to be very costly in many ways. And
I think you have to say that you're going to
reexamine it. We have to stand by our numbers.
We believe our numbers are right.
Speaker 1: Georgia has now.
All I want to do is find 11,780 votes. I've heard
that so many times now. But every single time
I hear it, I. Cannot process that that actually
happened and all that was surrounding that wasn't
just him calling, trying to get Brad Raffensperger
to throw out the election results and find 11,780
votes that didn't exist and proclaim him the
winner. It was also him coming up with this
alternate elector scheme, having a vice president
at the time, Mike Pence. Reject the actual actors,
pretend fake electors were the real ones and
install Trump the president. Throw us into a
constitutional crisis. A coup, a non military coup
was being attempted there. Luckily it didn't work.
But he absolutely needs to be held accountable.
And then a little bit here from Yahoo! News. While
Tuesday's arraignment of former President Donald
Trump marked the first time a former US president
has had ever been charged with criminal offenses,
it likely won't be the last. By summer's end,
Trump could be charged in no fewer than four
separate criminal investigations. Oh, goodness.
In fact, while Trump's indictment stemming from
his 130,000 hush money payment and thousand dollar
hush money payment to adult film star Stormy
Daniels represents a legal threat to the former
president. The others may carry a greater risk of
serious consequences, including a possible prison
sentence. As most people recognize, it's hard to
picture Trump being sent to prison, especially for
these Stormy Daniels. Case. But if we're going to
see that happen or at least him get house arrest.
Then I do think it'll come from one of the
other cases. And of course, you have the
federal investigation into his mishandling and
obstruction in regard to the documents, classified
documents. You have the federal investigation
into January six and the attempts to overturn
the election. You have the Georgia investigation,
two attempts to overturn the election, and then
you have the Manhattan district attorney's
investigation of the Stormy Daniels hush money
payment. So a lot going on there for Trump. We
have much more on the other side of this break